Does the world need to rapidly
convert to using renewable energy
to save the planet from global
warming? That was the topic of a
Soho forum debate held at
the Sheen Center in New York City
on Monday, August 15th,
2022.
Andrew Dessler, the director of the
Texas Center for Climate Studies at
Texas A&M University, argued that
fossil fuels are endangering life
on the planet by causing global
warming through greenhouse gas
emissions. He contended that solar
and wind represent a safe,
reliable and cost effective means
to decarbonize the electric
grid. Steven Koonin, who served
as Under Secretary for science
at the Department of Energy during
the Obama administration, argued
that making large and rapid
reductions in greenhouse gas
emissions aren't necessary to
protect the earth.
He also contended that doing so
isn't cost effective and that
it's immoral.
The debate was moderated by Soho
Forum director Gene Epstein.
The affirmative resolution reads
Climate science compels
us to make large and rapid
reductions in climate emissions.
Andrew Dessler for the affirmative.
Andrew, please come to the stage.
Speaking for the negative.
Steven Koonin.
Steven, please come to the stage.
Jane, please close
the voting.
Andrew, you have 17
and half minutes to speak for the
resolution.
Take it away, Andrew.
Thank you.
And if you have a crinkly lossage,
it won't bother me.
So feel free to pop it out.
You see my slides?
Okay, so as I was saying, this is
30,000 years
of or 30,000 years
of history are the last 20,000, the
next 10,000. This is the last
glacial maximum.
So that's dinosaurs are not
dinosaurs. That's ice sheets,
mastodons,
ice, thousands of feet thick
over North America.
And then you warm up out of it into
their glacial.
And then this pink band is the
fossil fuel era
in the long span of Earth's
history.
Fossil fuels can be this brief
spark in our history.
So it's only a couple hundred years,
you know, maybe we'll stop burning
fossil fuels in a few decades, maybe
in a few centuries.
But we're not going to be burning
fossil fuels in a few thousand
years. Just really aren't enough
recoverable fossil fuel.
So it's a couple of hundred years
and you see the temperature is going
to spike and then emissions
will end and the temperature will
not cool off. Very quickly, I'll
take 100,000 years for temperatures
to come back down. So what we do
during this pink band is
going to be irreversible,
basically.
Now, my argument here
is that this is a tremendous
amount of warming that should scare
the crap out of you.
All right. Now, let me back in.
They explain why I think
that.
So the difference between an ice
age and interglacial is ten
degrees Fahrenheit.
And there's really no no dispute
about this number. Lots of people
have worked on it. We really
understand it. If you cool the
planet by ten degrees Fahrenheit
global average, you end up with
thousands of feet of ice over North
America, sea levels 300 feet
lower.
Now, if you look at what we might
do, six degrees.
60% of an ice age.
Now, it's not in the same direction.
We're not cooling towards an ice
age. We are warming past an ice age
and it's going to remake the
planet.
And many of you, I see a lot of
young people in the audience.
You're going to live through this.
Okay. So you have skin in the game?
I don't have as much skin in the
game. I don't plan on living through
the 21st century, but my kids
do and a lot of you all do
now.
So this is enough to basically
re shape the planet
when you walk out your front door
and 2100 a six degree warmer planet,
you're not going to recognize it.
So how do we know
this? Well, first of all, we've
already warmed about two degrees.
This black dot is where we are now.
This is a little ice age.
We're about two degrees above that.
And we can already see
extremely big impacts
just from two degrees.
One third of the ultimate warming.
Oh, I should say when I talk about
six degrees, that's kind of a
business as usual.
If we decide we want to burn lots of
fossil fuels, it's going to be more
than that. And if we're wise,
it can be a lot less than that.
That's and that's essentially what
we're trying to decide in this
debate. Now, this is what we already
see with two degrees.
You know, you see the U.S.,
Southwest Lake Mi, Lake Powell
is running out of water, literally
a Hurricane Harvey, an
unbelievable.
I lived through that in College
Station about 90 miles from Houston.
I can tell you it was an
unbelievable rainstorm.
Now, in the Pacific Northwest,
heat wave lit in Canada, 121
degrees, and next day it burned
down.
Now there's an entire
field of science called extreme
event attribution, where they can go
into these events and they can ask
the question, did climate change
play a role?